so we want to dive into the war powers
debate with white house director of
global engagement under president obama
brett bruin former trump 2020 press
communications director aaron perrini
and former national security council
chief of staff fred fleitz all right
brett let's begin with you uh i i think
it's fair to say most people feel like
you have to go through congressional
lawmakers if you're going to involve
american troops in a war
this seems to be obvious to me is the
white house not seeing it this way
no kevin i think what the white house is
seeing right now is a potential threat
threat to american citizens in ukraine
as well as our nato allies and ukraine
itself and so there are certain powers
that are vested within the presidency
vested uh within the commander-in-chief
and and that is what i think is
necessary in order to keep our nation
safe and quite frankly to keep the
confidence of our allies strong erin a
lot of people in washington and i
imagine elsewhere around the country
simply feel like
what does this have to do with me does
it help the guy in the barca lounge here
in ames iowa why are we over there and
in particular why are we endangering
american forces when the border between
ukraine and russia would appear to be
for many a problem between russia and
ukraine
there are a couple of points i would
make on why this matters one it matters
because you are looking at an
administration that has not been strong
when it comes to national security and
national security policies especially
when it comes to emboldening putin and
russia and gifting them nordstrom too
there was an opportunity for congress to
stand up in january provide further
sanctions to stop the nordstrom 2
pipeline and stop an embolding russia
and instead 44 senate democrats voted
against that so it does matter to the
american people what is happening
especially because ukraine is such an
ally of the united states and joe biden
sold them out and so did some senate
democrats so quickly
fred i just wonder it seems that the u.s
is very strong about what may be
happening between the russians and the
ukrainians and yet it doesn't appear
to have taken on the same level of
urgency at least among some of the
powers in europe am i misreading that i
don't see the germans for example
overly exercised about this possibility
am i wrong
no i think that's an important
observation the germans have definitely
not been as involved because germany is
so dependent on russian uh natural gas
and has they've shut down their their
nuclear power plants they're shutting
down their coal-fired electricity plants
nato really has been divided we see
members of of nato members european
leaders meeting with russia separately
the french have convened meetings with
the germans the ukrainians the russians
without the united states so i think
putin has achieved something here he has
divided nato to a certain point
but but i also would argue that one
problem here is that ukraine is not a
nato member and uh we're not going to
send american troops into a into a
country like that which would start a
nuclear possibly a nuclear war with
russia when ukraine's not a member of
nato it's a difficult position we have
to stand our ground on
self-determination and the rule of law
but no troops can go into ukraine yeah
very interesting that you point that out
i want to bring you back into the
conversation brett there are american
forces in ukraine at this very hour the
administration acknowledging that they
are clearly in harm's way as long as
they are on the ground if you're
advising this administration what would
be the number one bit of advice you
might give them
well i think one we've got to up our
game it's a football weekend vladimir
putin is playing in the super bowl of
international strategy and we're still
unfortunately trying to figure out how
to get the ball down the field
and i think it's
unfortunate because
we've lost confidence from a lot of
allies and that is why i think you're
seeing the kind of divisions and the
doubts in germany france elsewhere in
europe so we have got to put forward a
much stronger strategy you know today we
heard from jake sullivan a warning to
americans i think we need a much
stronger warning to vladimir putin and
not just slapping on a few more economic
sanctions you know aaron whenever i
think about this administration and its
broad support from the mainstream media
i think that pretty much goes without
saying and yet there have been some even
the new york times wondering if this
particular administration
is in a particularly weak position as it
relates to trying to rein in russian
aggression
what is your sense as we look now
perilously perhaps at the next
24 48 72 hours
yeah this has been an administration
mired by geopolitical disaster after
disaster i mean you look at afghanistan
it was only a matter of time until the
media came around to reporting the facts
that joe biden has been weak when it's
come to geopolitical politics here
he has emboldened putin they went as far
as blink and going out and saying that
the pipeline was pretty much done even
though sanctions had stopped it up to
that point the nordstrom 2 pipeline
which empowers russia to circumvent
ukraine possibly destroying their gas
infrastructure altogether to give energy
to other countries when you see that
when you see a president not standing
and putting forward congressionally
mandated sanctions that were working and
emboldening putin of course you're going
to see the media eventually in somewhat
some limited fashion start to turn on
them joe biden has weakened the united
states across the board afghanistan was
one and what we see here in ukraine
should worry the american people and the
world as a whole because this feckless
weak leadership is endangering
countless individuals honestly read the
last 30 seconds to you
based on everything you're seeing right
now is there any way that there is a
pullback from the precipice either by
the russians or perhaps some way somehow
the u.s and the french get vladimir
putin to reconsider
i think an invasion is inevitable not
simply because of the accelerated troop
buildup but because of the way british
and french officials were snubbed
this week when they visited moscow
i don't think putin is interested in
talking he's not interested in consent
in
concession from the west we should still
try but i think asking america to get
out of ukraine right now was the right
move
fred aaron and brett thank you as always
we appreciate your time jane joining us
here tonight on fox news at night if
something happens here over the weekend
obviously we may reach out again in the
meantime you all have a good weekend
thank you
thanks kevin good to be here hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else